♪ (HBO INTRO PLAYS) ♪
RODNEY BARNES:
Welcome back to the official
Winning Time Podcast from HBO!
I'm Rodney Barnes,
executive producer on the show.
REPORTER: Magic and the Lakers
are back to defend their title.
REPORTER 2:
What a time to be alive.
RODNEY:
Over the next seven weeks,
I'll be joined by actors,
directors and key collaborators,
to break down each episode
of season two.
JERRY BUSS:
It's not about basketball.
It's about winning.
RODNEY: We'll also unpack
the real events
that make it into the show
with sportswriter Jeff Pearlman.
His book about
the Showtime Lakers of the 1980s
inspired Winning Time.
JEFF PEARLMAN: So after
the Lakers win this game
that they shouldn't have won,
on a court they shouldn't
have won on,
the fans went crazy,
and all of these things
actually happened.
RODNEY: Listen to HBO's official
Winning Time Podcast
on Sunday, August 6th,
right after the premiere
of season two on Max.
New podcast episodes come out
every Sunday night
immediately following
new episodes of the series.
Listen on Max or wherever
you get your podcasts.